Use code TV and get $50
off plus a free foot rest.
>> Tucker: THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
STORIES THAT WE DEBATED NOT
DOING BECAUSE IT’S SO SAD.
IT’S CRUSHINGLY SAD.
BUT IN THE END, WE DECIDE WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO DO IT
BECAUSE IT’S TRUE.
13 SERVICEMEN WERE KILLED
YESTERDAY IN A BOMBING OUTSIDE
THE KABUL AIRPORT.
ONE OF THEM WAS A U.S. MARINE
CALLED KAREEM.
THIS VIDEO FROM AFGHANISTAN
COULD BE THE LAST TAKEN OF HIM
BEFORE HIS DEATH.
>> SAY HI TO THE CAMERA.
HI.
>> HI.
WE FRIENDS?
FRIENDS?
FRIEND?
YEAH?
FRIEND.
>> Tucker: HIS FATHER IS STEVE
AND HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.
OUR HEARTS BREAK FOR YOU.
I’M SORRY.
SO --
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IT’S HARD TO KNOW
WHAT TO ASK YOU OTHER THAN TO
EXTEND OUR SINCERE FOR-REAL
HEART-FELT SYMPATHIES.
HOW ARE YOU DOING 24 HOURS
LATER?
>> WELL, I’M GOING ON ABOUT 36
HOURS, I BELIEVE, THAT I’VE BEEN
UP.
I STILL IN SHOCK.
THE FAMILY IS DEVASTATED.
HIS MOTHER, WHO IS AN EXCELLENT
MOM, YOU KNOW, IS DOING THE BEST
THAT SHE CAN CONSIDERING THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
SO THE REASON THAT WE WANTED TO
TALK TO YOU, JUST TO REMIND
EVERYBODY WATCHING AND PEOPLE
KNOW THIS, THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE
SERVING OUR COUNTRY AND DYING
BECAUSE THEY’VE BEEN ASKED TO
PUT THEIR LIVES AT RISK.
SO WERE YOU CONCERNED YOUR BOY
IS OVER THERE IN THE FINAL DAYS
OF OUR OCCUPATION, WERE YOU
WORRIED FOR HIM?
>> OH, YEAH, DEFINITELY.
HE HAD VOICED SOME WORRY, TOO,
TO THE FAMILY EARLIER, PRIOR TO
HIM GOING.
LOOKED AT THE WAY THAT THE
TALIBAN HAD, YOU KNOW,
INFILTRATED THE WHOLE COUNTRY SO
FAST AND WE WERE JUST KIND OF
LEFT TO THIS ONE LITTLE AIRPORT
CONCERNED ME.
THE VIDEOS THAT WE WERE GETTING
AND THE PICTURES THAT WE WERE
GETTING FROM HIM LOOKED SOMEWHAT
CHAOTIC.
WE GOT THE VIDEO THAT YOU HAD
JUST PLAYED AND WE GOT OTHER
ONES WHERE HE WAS REALLY
INTERACTING WITH, YOU KNOW, THE
LOCALS.
AND WAS IN AWE IN HIS APPROACH
TO HIS DIFFICULT JOB.
SO JUST, YOU KNOW, THAT VIDEO
THAT YOU SAW AND HIS PICTURES
AND HOW HE HANDLED IT PUT US AT
EASE TO WHERE WE FELT LIKE HE’S
ALL RIGHT.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS SO BITTER
ABOUT THIS IS HOW CHAOTIC IT
WAS.
IF THIS HAD BEEN HANDLED FROM
BAGRAM AIR BASE WHICH THE U.S.
CONTROLLED FOR 20 YEARS, THIS
WOULDN’T HAVE HAPPENED.
IS THAT YOUR VIEW?
>> WELL, YEAH, I MEAN, THESE
ARE, OF COURSE, MY VIEWS.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HIS
VIEW AS A MARINE.
YOU KNOW, THE LOYALTY THAT HE
HAS THERE.
I NEVER SERVED.
BUT YES, MY VIEW FROM WHAT I SAW
OF THE AIRPORT THAT THEY’RE IN,
LOOKED LIKE A TURKEY SHOOT.
IT’S FUNNELED IN TO A SINGLE
FILE-TYPE ENTRY POINT AT WHICH
IF YOU HAVE IN SORT OF CHAOS OF
ANY SORT, THEY WOULD ALL LIKE
GATHER TO THAT ONE FUNNELED
AREA, WHICH THEY WOULD ALL BE
ACCESSED.
THAT’S WHAT HAPPENED.
IT WAS JUST BASICALLY SO CHAOTIC
AND NOT REALLY PLANNED OUT.
NOW, I’M A CARPENTER AND I COULD
SPOT THAT WITH MY UNTRAINED
MILITARY EYE.
>> Tucker: YEAH, DID SEEM PRETTY
OBVIOUS.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THE MARINE
CORPS, THE POLITICAL LEADERSHIP
IN THIS COUNTRY SINCE YOUR SON’S
DEATH?
>> YEAH, THEY HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLE.
SO YOU KNOW, BASICALLY WHAT HAD
HAPPENED WAS HOW I FOUND OUT IS
I WAS GLUED TO THE TV ALL DAY
YESTERDAY.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I HAD WOKEN
UP AND I WASN’T FEELING WELL.
I FELT LIKE SOMETHING WAS WRONG.
MY WIFE FELT THERE WAS SOMETHING
WRONG.
YOU KNOW, AS WE GO DOWN STAIRS,
WE REALIZE THIS HAD HAPPENED.
NOW, YOU KNOW, WE’RE LIKE, WELL,
THERE’S SOME LEGITIMACY TO HOW
WE’RE FEELING.
SO WE’RE -- I’M GLUED TO THE TV
ALL DAY.
I HAVE MY -- AND I SEE IT SAYS
THREE WOUNDED AND THREE KILLED
AND TEN KILLED, THEN 12, THEN
13.
YOU KNOW, SO MANY AFGHANS.
I’M TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT TIME
THIS ACTUALLY TOOK PLACE SO I
CAN REFERENCE WHEN HE WAS
WORKING TO GET SOME SORT OF
INSIGHT.
THEN THEY SAID THE PRESIDENT WAS
GOING TO TALK I BELIEVE AT 1:00.
SO I FELT LIKE, YOU KNOW, MAYBE
FROM THAT SPEECH I WOULD GET
WHETHER OR NOT ALL THE FAMILIES
HAD BEEN CONTACTED OR IF THEY
STILL HAD BEEN CONTACTED.
PREVIOUSLY I HAD SEEN THAT, YOU
KNOW, THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION
WOULD NORMALLY CONTACT PEOPLE
LIKE FIRST.
LIKE THE ACTUAL PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
SO I HAD SOME SORT OF SENSE LIKE
HEY, OKAY, MAYBE THAT WOULD
HAPPEN.
SO THEN THAT’S NOT HAPPENING.
THINGS ARE STILL TRANSPIRING TO
BE A LITTLE MORE GRAVE.
I START GOOGLING.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE FOR THE
MILITARY TO, YOU KNOW,INFORM THE
NEXT OF KIN?
SOMEHOW FROM THE INTERNET I
GATHERED ABOUT EIGHT HOURS.
THIS IS ABOUT AFTER HE TALKED.
AFTER HE TALKED HE SAID, YOU
KNOW, I BELIEVE HE HAD SAID
THEY’RE STILL GOING TO BE
CONTACTED OR I THINK MAYBE THE
COMMENTATOR SAID THERE WILL BE
SOME KNOCK ON THE DOORS TONIGHT.
I DIDN’T KNOW IF THERE WOULD BE
A KNOCK ON THE DOOR OR CALL.
SO AFTER HIS SPEECH THAT HE DID,
I THEN GOT MY PHONE AND PUT MY
PHONE DOWN BY THE TELEVISION.
NOW I HAD THE CABLE ON THAT HAD
THE FOUR DIFFERENT NETWORKS ON
MY CABLE.
I HAD FOX NEWS, BBC, CNN AND
SOMETHING ELSE.
I WAS JUST -- THE REASON I HAD
THAT SO I COULD SEE THE OPTICS
OF THE FOUR CHANNELS AND PICK
ONE I WANTED TO GET MY
INFORMATION FROM.
WELL, I ALSO STARTED TO THINK,
YOU KNOW, THEY MIGHT POSSIBLY
COME HERE.
SO WHAT I HAD DONE, I GOT MY
PHONE THAT HAS THE CAMERA AT THE
FRONT PORCH AND I PUT THAT DOWN.
SO IF ANYBODY WAS TO WALK UP, I
COULD RUSH OUTSIDE AND INTERCEPT
THEM.
I DIDN’T WANT IF SOMETHING
HAPPENS TO MY SON THAT THESE
MARINES -- NOTHING AGAINST
THEM -- WOULD TELL MY FAMILY.
I FELT LIKE THAT WAS MY
RESPONSIBILITY.
SO I FINALLY REALIZED THEY’RE
NOT GOING TO COME AT 3:00.
THEY’RE GOING TO COME BETWEEN
5:00 AND 10:00 WHEN EVERYBODY IS
HOME FROM WORK.
SO I REALIZED, YOU KNOW, 5:00 TO
10:00.
IF I CAN MAKE IT, EVEN IF I
HAVEN’T HEARD FROM HIM, I KNOW
HE’S ALL RIGHT AND HE DOESN’T
HAVE A WAY TO CONTACT ME BECAUSE
THEY SHUT DOWN INTERNET OR CELL
SERVICE OR WHATEVER.
7:15, I SEE SOMETHING IN THE
CORNER OF MY EYE ON MY PHONE.
THREE PEOPLE ARE WALKING UP MY
DRIVEWAY.
MY OTHER SON, HIS BROTHER, HAD
GONE TO A FOOTBALL GAME AND HAD
TWO FRIENDS.
I WAS HOPING THAT IT WAS HIM.
AS SOON AS I SAW THEM TURN THE
CORNER, THREE MARINE SUITS, MY
LIFE CHANGED FOREVER.
I WENT DOWN THERE AND MET THEM.
I THINK I DID BEFORE THEY EVEN
KNOCKED ON THE DOOR.
ALL I KEPT SAYING -- THIS GOES
TO THE POINT THAT YOU’RE ASKING.
DID ANY SERVICE COME AND ADDRESS
TO US.
YES.
AND THEY WERE INCREDIBLE.
THESE YOUNG MEN WERE SO -- HAD
SO MUCH EMPATHY AND SO CONCERNED
WITH ME AND MY FAMILY WHO
LUCKILY MY FAMILY WASN’T THERE.
IT WAS ME AT THE TIME.
I THANK GOD, YOU KNOW, I THANK
JESUS THAT THAT HAPPENED, THAT I
WAS ABLE TO INTERCEPT THEM.
THEY WERE THERE FOR LIKE FIVE
MINUTES.
I WAS LIKE LET’S SIGN WHATEVER
PAPERS WE HAVE TO SIGN NOW.
BUT YOU HAVE TO LEAVE BECAUSE I
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF MY FAMILY
AND I DON’T WANT SOMEONE TO COME
WHILE YOU’RE HERE.
THEY WERE TOTALLY
UNDERSTANDABLE.
IT DAWNED ON ME THAT YES, MAYBE
I DON’T NEED THE CONDOLENCES
FROM THEM BUT I DON’T WANT TO --
I DON’T WANT TO TAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY FROM MY OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS.
MY WIFE, MY SON.
SO I ASKED THEM, LOOK THEY’RE AT
A FOOTBALL GAME FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL, WATCHING A FOOTBALL
GAME.
CAN YOU WAIT DOWN THE STREET
UNTIL THEY COME?
I CAN SEE IF THEY WANT YOU TO
COME AND DO YOUR CONDOLENCES
PRESENTATION.
THOSE BOYS SAT OUT THERE FOR
FOUR HOURS.
FOR FOUR HOURS THEY SAT OUT
THERE UNTIL THEY CAME.
UNTIL MY WIFE CAME, WHICH SHE --
IT WAS NOT GOOD.
I COULD NOT HAVE THEM COME TO
THE HOUSE.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
LIKE I SAID, I HAD BEEN UP 36
HOURS.
I WAS IN AWE.
JUST HUMBLED BY THE -- BY THEIR
PERFORMANCE.
>> Tucker: I APPRECIATE IT,
STEVE, YOUR TELLING US THAT.
GOD BLESS YOU.